(light music)
(sneakers squeaking)
- [Woman] What is up, sir?
- Hello.
- [Woman] Welcome back.
- Thank you.
Thanks for having me.
Hey everybody.
How are you?
Morning, real pleasure.
Uber and Airbnb, they're not
anomalies they're the preview.
Everything is
gonna be eaten up.
All human inefficiencies can
be solved and you all know
that in this room.
Thank you guys.
(applause)
- We have Chick-fil-A
lunches on the way out there.
- What's up guys?
- [Man] Hey, hey.
- [Gary] Sup?
I don't think Jordan is
going to let me eat this.
- [Man 2] Chick-fil-A's probably
in your diet.
- [Woman 2] There is some salad.
- [Gary] There's salad.
- [Woman 2] Yeah.
- From 12 to 2 we've got access
to this big lake and we're going
to start our yard
games tournament.
- [DRock] Whoa.
- At six we'll go to the stadium
we're going to have a catered
dinner at the
stadium in our lounge.
- My go to fun fact is I once
judged the Miss America contest.
(laughter)
- And then we'll go to the game.
- [DRock] Thank you for
narrating DailyVee.
- [Gary] I'm super
bitter, about this morning.
- [Mickey] Yeah?
- [Gary] And I
really blame myself.
I missed the baseline jumper.
- I know.
- And that was a wide-open shot.
My guy was tough.
- [Mickey] Dylan?
Post is crafty.
- [Gary] He is crafty.
He tried which is bad.
(laughter)
I hate guys that try.
No, effort is such a
variable in games like that.
Hello.
- [Group] Hello.
- [Gary] Hello.
(cheers)
In New York we had like
seven charter buses but we
really needed five.
I looked at how many
empty seats there was.
I'm very impressed with
you guys this is exactly
the perfect size--
- Very efficient here.
- Super efficient.
Those New York jerk offs.
(laughter)
So fancy.
Is that a Goosebumps hat?
- Yes.
- That's pretty awesome.
I think that Goosebumps hat
is at least 30 bucks on eBay.
- [Man 3] She wears it
a couple times a week.
- Yeah.
- I think she's
getting the $30 out of it.
- Would she take a hundo?
- Well, that's a question.
- Yeah, she would, right?
What about 60?
- [Man 3] Monica.
- 40?
- [Man 3] Monica how much
money would it take for
the Goosebumps hat?
Gary wants to know.
- [Monica] What?
- Like for real. For real.
- [Woman 3] I feel like you
can find it online for
not that expensive.
- [Monica] I bought
the only one.
I've searched for it online--
- I'm going to find
it in one second.
(laughter)
- [Man 4] Gary's,
he's got a guy.
- [Gary] My guy is named Google.
It's called Goosebumps hat.
- [Monica] You can't find it.
I've looked for it 'cause
everyone's like
where'd you get that?
- [Man 5] She's just
trying to drive your price up.
- [Man 6] Yeah.
It's true. It's true.
- [Woman 4] 500 bucks right now.
- [Man 6] 500, yeah.
- [Gary] You mean this one?
(group cheers)
I will miss Xander's
championship
Little League game
for a Jets game.
And it's not even like a debate.
Which means that I have to be
smart about that 'cause that's
obviously emotional and
can bite me in the butt
years down the line.
So I have to really push my kids
towards Saturday activity things.
By the way, I'm being
dead serious about that.
- [Man 7] Shut it down.
Are they old enough
now to where
they're starting to root
for the Jets?
- [Gary] Yeah, oh yeah.
They really, like Misha is
really actually starting to like
get into it which is really cool
and Xander is, Xander will do
anything Misha does.
(laughter)
He's a four-year-old girl.
That's who he is right now.
(laughter)
It's all recitals.
He's just a four-year-old girl.
So, the Knicks have a really cool
tradition they play a afternoon
game during
Martin Luther King Day.
Even earlier than normal like a
12 noon game so I decided last
year that I was going to start
a tradition and take Misha and
then Xander, but Misha to that
will be our thing Martin Luther
King Day I'll stay in the
city we'll go to the Garden.
We'll spend the whole day, it'll
be nice tradition so I take her
first game I don't know if you
saw my Snapchat or Instagram
I got season tickets
on the floor.
So we're on the floor of
Madison Square Garden.
And I bring Misha and it's like
a really emotional moment for me
because I realize this is her
first game and my first game was
in the last row.
The singular last row of
Madison Square Garden.
So it's just kind of like you
can start really being like wow
we really made it as a family.
And I'm like, "Misha," and I
grabbed her, "do you know how
"lucky you are that you
get to sit right here
"right on the court?
"And daddy's first game was all
the way up there," and she goes,
"You sat in the
balcony, you're so lucky."
(laughter)
Just classic.
- That's adorable.
- That went down.
Jesus Christ.
- You're in the south, buddy.
- South is insane.
It is warm.
- Dude, we're gonna eat this.
- What?
- We're 100% eating this.
- I figured.
- Yeah. Take that.
There's water on there that
we should probably get too.
- [DRock] Yeah.
You don't do dressing, right?
- We're not gonna
dump dressing on that.
One sec.
- [DRock] Little lunchable.
- [Gary] Jesse
could be super strong?
Look at those fucking calves.
Just natural
infrastructure for success.
(upbeat music)
- [Man 8] Cannonball.
Woo.
- My go to fun fact is I once
judged the Miss America contest.
(laughter)
Do you remember that?
- Yeah.
- How quickly did you get pulled
over after you got your license?
Five days after I got my
license I was driving from the
Phillipsburg Mall back home and
I just had this freedom and
I went to go buy baseball cards
to make some money and I dragged
two of my friends 'cause it
was fun but my buddy like,
"Holy fuck, I'm so late
to get home."
He's like freaking out so I'm
like fuck so we drive and
we're in the country.
Where Jesse and I grew up,
this looks like
fuckin' New York City.
We're on this back road and
there's a car in front of me
that is going four and
the road is straight.
The road is super straight and
I could see everything and I'm
scared to go around him
because I been driving
for four minutes.
I'm still scared I'm
still like totally you know?
The way Jordan still
drives it sounds like.
I'm super like that and the
guy is like, "Please," and
I'm like, "Fuck, okay."
So I go around it in my
third friend goes,
"Oh shit. That's Mr. Wilson."
Mr. Wilson's my neighbor.
So now I'm like, "Fuck,
Mr. Wilson's going to tell on me
so I put my foot to the pedal,
I go fast and I roll through
this stop sign at the
bottom of the hill and
sure enough a cop's there.
Pulls me over comes up
and he's like not that agitated.
But he looks and he sees a
bunch of what he thinks are
beers on my floor.
Of course, this was
during my great drink
Stewart's root beer 24/7/365.
(laughter)
We get through that first
angst moment, he's like,
"What the fuck is that?"
And I'm like,
"Uh, oh it's Stewart's."
He's like, "Don't pick it up."
I'm like "Hey."
(laughter)
It's this whole thing.
So finally he's happy
that it's Stewart's.
I'm winning him over.
I'm doing my thing.
And all of a sudden this is how
far ahead of that guy I went,
the guy I passed stops
and tells the cop that
I'm crazy reckless
fucking past him on the other
side almost hit him, cop freaks
on me and drives me home.
(crowd groans)
- [Man 7] Sasha!
- Sasha worked 24/7.
Sasha's not home but my mom is,
the best part of this story,
the best part of this
story is cop takes me home.
Wants to talk to my mother.
I ring the doorbell because I'm
like I don't know, my sister's
answers who's three years
younger than me looks and has a
huge smile on her face.
(laughter)
She was the worst.
She was literally the worst.
She's the best but
she was a bad guy.
She's a bad guy she really is.
And that's my first experience.
I really, I really
am on a mission.
I really want my life's legacy
to be that I built the biggest
empire in business on good.
I'm very passionate about it.
The cool part about having
that mission is it starts by me
delivering for you guys.
I'm interested in people
when they're post VaynerMedia.
I feel like this is a club.
Would I prefer that
you're here forever?
Yes, I would.
Yes, I like continuity.
I'd like to think that
you love it so much.
I want to build something long
and forever but if you're not
I'm okay with that.
As happy as I am and as happy
as maybe 80% of people are here
there's nothing wrong with
you not being and
I want to have those talks.
Because ironically 90% of the
time it's literally like a
tweak or two and then you are.
I've been on this rampage for
the last two weeks in New York
and I would say 11 people
have taken us up on it and their
lives are completely different.
I would never want anyone that
works at VaynerMedia to have any
angst or not happiness on their
way to work and that's what
I feel like I do for a living.
- I never, I don't know it's
just insane a company that tries
so hard to make people
happy against the bottom line.
- [Gary] But you know what,
it's chipping that's what I do,
I just chip away, chip away.
That's why I don't
overreact or panic.
The truth is the truth.
- Yeah.
- The truth is going to win.
- I don't need to tell
people that I'm giving money.
- Yeah, people know.
- I just don't do that.
The people that are
closest to will know,
they'll tell some people.
The truth finds its way.
- Yeah.
- You know I'm not worried about
what people think about me now.
I worry about what people think
about me when I'm finished.
- Yeah, I mean you'll have
a stadium full of people.
- First time I've been to a
stadium where a professional
game was going on
and I saw none of it.
Not a play.
Great night.
Good day.
(light music)